will that stay in play
polanco tracks it down
very nice
with that wall over there too sometimes
you see guys
shy away plus i'm sure it was probably
curling toward the wall a little bit as
well
how about mr slam
from last night
it's a gomer homer with a few men on
base
[Applause]
this guy loves
getting the barrel out and hitting to
the pull side
he knew that one right away as well
110th career homer
34 degrees of launch angle last night
that was a towering blast
and his seven puts the nets on top
here's chase deyoung
he is a right-handed thrower
but he bats from the left side of the
plate
de young
coming up with his first big league head
it's gonna be for extra bases
the young with a two out double robles
was fooled i think on that
he thought he was going to maybe make a
catch he was angling in at that
he thought this was a little like flare
off the end of the bat but that ball was
right on the screws driven hard
hit more than 102 miles an hour
well that's no cheapy
that is a legit hit
one and two
now
swing and a miss
follow a speedo not necessarily a
strikeout guy
picks the best possible time for number
two
don't have to elevate with 98 you can
elevate with 89 and still get the job
done
[Music]
paulo espino gets count leverage
bouncing ball on the first pitch
garcia takes care of it so does paolo
espino
he's through four with no runs on three
hits
struck out three in a row the fourth was
juan soto to begin this inning no out
since the base is full
and a late swing and a miss struck him
out
[Applause]
fastball
upstairs
[Music]
rearing back and giving him a little
extra heat
he's behind two and one nowhere to put
him
got him to pop it up
frazier
has the final out
and good job by chase de young stranding
the bases loaded
watch him work
back in the second inning check out this
12-6 or to get ben gamel swinging
and then in the fourth the pirates put a
couple runners on
espino gets evans on a fastball gets
gambled to tap out
to the right side a little fist pump
he sure loves it that ball hacked out to
left center schwarber playing way off
the line and that's the way left
fielders have played in this ballpark
from the day it opened in 2008 you will
hardly ever see a left fielder at
nationals park not playing in front of
the opposing bullpen
off speed
fortunately for the nets that ball
missed the second base back
it almost hit the
base on its way by
one for 16 in nine games
and a slow roller espino hits the moving
target
josh bell follow espino
good qualify for a win a little later
he's due to bat first what an outing
from this guy
just about ready to wrap up these middle
innings
that's a good start
josh bell is going to drop one into
right center
and now three for four career against
chris stratton
on for the second time
yeah kind of like that
not getting too
antsy at the big league level taking the
walk two on one out for three two
they did bases loaded one out
count remains one and two
rub lays to right not very deep
polanco's always had a good arm
bell maybe about three steps and you
don't run on gregory polacco there two
outs
but he's gonna pop it up to center
reynolds in that sunfield out there
gonna catch it about
375 feet away
but ants are frustrated again they've
stranded eight
in this one-nothing game
let's see what the right-hander has for
him
base hit to left with the shift on
juan soto's second such hit of this
series as a competitor
he would not hate to punctuate this
series against his former team with a
long home run oh you know he would yeah
god you know i'm sure he has a lot of
fond memories of pittsburgh but the team
trades you they
don't want you around anymore
josh bell
as if on cue
deep right center
cu
later
fastball inner third
and a guy who has such long arms
does a really nice job of getting his
hands inside and finding the barrel
he's down the line at fair
and he's gonna try for two
he's in there a double for hayes here in
the eighth inning
out and through
and hayes is coming in he'll score on
the rbi single by reynolds and here come
the bucks
your best hitters up this uh
inning
frazier he hit one right on the
on the button but it was a line out
ground ball right side
a former pirate
makes the catch on the throw and that's
it financial sweep
the pittsburgh pirates
three to two eight to one
three to one